an anti-semitic attacker yelled Kanye
2024 while committing the attack and we
are going to talk about what happened
and importantly this is not about Kanye
being legally responsible for the attack
or anything like it this is about
realizing that when high-profile
celebrities like Kanye West make
anti-semitic comments it contributes to
normalizing and accepting anti-Semitism
in society that's the point that we are
making here let's go to the Washington
Post article attacker yells Kanye 2024
during anti-semitic assault police say
NYPD is investigating an alleged attack
in Central Park this week in which a man
in his mid-40s assaulted a 63 year old
man and spewed anti-semitic comments
before yelling out Kanye 2024 of course
a reference to Kanye's anti-semitic
rhetoric the older man was walking in
Central Park about 7 30 PM Wednesday
when the other man allegedly hit him
from behind according to police when the
older man fell to the ground he broke
his hand and chipped a tooth the
attacker then uttered numerous
anti-semitic comments towards the man
according to police before the attacker
fled on a bicycle with a trailer
featuring a sign reading hungry disabled
police say he referenced the artist
formerly known as Kanye West who has
issued several anti-semitic tirades
senkanye 2024 63 year old man has not
been publicly identified anti-semitic
attacks in the U.S are at an all-time
high so when high-profile individuals
make statements or they engage in
behaviors that are perceived as
anti-semitic or that are anti-Semitic it
can give the impression that this type
of bigotry is acceptable and mainstream
and in fact when it comes specifically
to anti-Semitism it's very popular it's
very in Vogue to say we don't even
really need to treat it as seriously as
other isms because Jews are privileged
in 2022. we've talked about that
extensively and we've talked about how
that very refrain is in and of itself
based on anti-semitic tropes and
stereotypes but this is why it's not as
simple as many of the emails I get from
some of you lovely people who say it
doesn't matter that Kanye's anti-semitic
fine maybe he's anti-semitic some people
email me and they say the stuff's Kanye
Kanye is saying is true okay there's
people who recognize yes these are
anti-semitic tropes but it doesn't
matter just Kanye it doesn't matter it's
a vicious circle in fact and it matters
very much the use of anti-Semitic
language or imagery by celebrities fuels
the spread of that very misinformation
and those conspiracy theories and tropes
which then in the followers of these
celebrities creates a new cycle of
emboldening and furthering and
exacerbating those very beliefs which
only creates more of it it's a vicious
circle and we've seen many examples of
this it's not only Kanye I mean listen
we can go back to Henry Ford if you
really want to but without going back
that far Mel Gibson in 2006 Mel Gibson
had this incident where he was arrested
drunk driving and he made a bunch of
anti-Semitic statements to the officer
he said to the guy are you a Jew crazy
but I believe the officer was Jewish
which is just I mean that's another
whole incredible coincidence uh saying
the Jews are responsible for the wars in
the world and all this stuff and you
know he eventually apologized and I
think Mel Gibson's acting again I don't
know but at the time it created a lot of
this Mel Gibson's willing to say stuff a
lot of people in Hollywood aren't
willing to say Louis Farrakhan we've
talked about many times before he's the
leader of the Nation of Islam very long
history of anti-Semitic statements
blamed the Jews for 9 11. uh typical
stuff Jews are actually the ones in
control of the government that type of
thing he has a significant following and
there are lots of folks in the Nation of
Islam who maybe don't come in with
particular views about Jews but there
they end up informed by Louis Farrakhan
and then you have a whole new generation
of people who repeat the same stuff
um an ice cube had an incident rapper
Ice Cube promoted some conspiracy
theories about Jews on social media
claimed Jews are responsible for the
slave trade which isn't true and he
um responded by saying I'm not promoting
anti-Semitism I'm raising questions
about the history of slavery questions
that are very extensively answered by by
history so it's a vicious circle of
stuff
The Vicious Circle itself perpetuates
the belief and then it creates more of a
problem and anti-Semitism like other
forms of bigotry is often based on
negative stereotypes and prejudices
about Jews the prejudices themselves
make it easier for people to believe the
conspiracy theories and even if there's
no evidence to support them it's a
feedback loop it's like if you put a
microphone up to a speaker and then you
know a feedback loop there are also
psychological factors because research
has found that people are more likely to
believe conspiracy theories when they're
feeling anxious or uncertain in a time
of Crisis or change they become more
susceptible to believing this stuff and
we have a right-wing party in the United
States the Republican party that for a
decade now has been based on using fear
and making people afraid that they're
going to lose their way of life or their
lives or whatever and that actually
primes people to be even more likely to
fall for this stuff in the first place
so the full circle of the Kanye
anti-Semitism and we'll follow up on the
story probably on a forthcoming bonus
show before you go if you enjoyed this
video and want to see more please make
sure to subscribe to my YouTube channel
you can click the Subscribe button below
or above or wherever it is on your
screen and if you want to support my
work even more strongly the best way is
to get a membership at joinpakman.com
And subscribe to the podcast for the
David packman show there you can check
out interviews longer clips and much
more it's on all the big podcasting
platforms just search for the David
packman show and all the links are also
Down Below in the video description